good evening and welcome to brookline
booksmith tonight my name is Jim Burley
I'm the events director thanks for
coming thank you for your continuing
support for your award-winning
neighborhood independent bookstore to
keep up with the events in this series
check us out online at brookline
booksmith com pick up a copy of our
schedule sign up to be on our mailing
list you can do all this at the counters
while you're buying human trials which
is on sale tonight and what you all must
purchase we're very thrilled to have our
neighbor Susan Quinn with us tonight her
articles have appeared in Atlantic
Monthly in the New York Times Magazine
among other places she is a biographer
extraordinaire the author of two
celebrated studies Madame Curie Marie
Curie a life and a mind of her own the
life of Karen horney this is Susan's
latest human trials scientists investors
and patients in quest for a cure a
remarkable look at the bumpy ride to
find cures for rheumatoid arthritis and
multiple sclerosis with empathy and with
edge Susan Maps the race with astounding
and Susan maps the race with astounding
inside access and with the clearest
devise the great novelist Crispo Julian
wrote the same talents that makes Susan
Quinn such an immensely gifted
biographer serve her well in this fine
new book she's a tireless researcher a
resourceful historian and she writes
individual scenes that have the pace and
power one expects to find in a novel
human trials is absolutely fascinating a
window into the world behind the medical
marvels we often take for granted and
they're very human costs Susan will read
to us for a bit take a few of your
questions and then be available to sign
copies of this book please help me
welcome Susan Quint
thank you Jim it's a pleasure to be
speaking tonight under the auspices of
one of Boston's very best independent
bookstores the brookline booksmith
because I know this is an audience of
writers and of passionate readers I'm
going to talk first before I read about
some of the writing issues I faced in
this book and then I'll read a little
I've been working on this book for the
past five years actually five years is a
relatively short time for me my
biography of Karen horn I took six years
and the one of Marie Curie took seven
years so I'm getting faster and this
book human trials presented very
different challenges than the previous
two books biographies have a natural
shape an obvious chronology the story of
a life in fact the challenge in
biography as Catherine drinker Bowen
once said is to break the back of the
chronology to find connections by
foreshadowing buyback shadowing between
events to avoid the tendency to
tediously report what happened next next
next next in a life in human trials I
was faced with an entirely different
problem from the start I was cleared
that I didn't want to write the story of
a lone scientist on the quest for a cure
for Disease X or Y that would have been
a lot like biography but that wasn't
what I had in mind I wanted to tell the
larger human story of all the people and
even the mice who contribute to drug
discovery these people were in different
places and didn't necessarily know each
other and their actions were often
happening simultaneously and or
overlapping the only thing that tied
them together was the quest for a cure
and yet I had to lay out the story in a
way that would give the reader a sense
of continuity and forward motion the
image that comes to mind is of a doll
over here in the dollhouse is the
laboratory with the postdocs and the
mice and over there is the clinic with
the doctors and the despairing patients
then along comes the venture capitalist
he's up here on some high floor of a
Manhattan office building and then you
have the suits the company people the
CEO and the vice president's with their
offices out on 128 and there are the
doctors who are called investigators and
there are the patients in the trial who
are struggling with illnesses in small
towns and big cities all over the United
States and Canada it's a cast of
thousands and there are rooms in the
house that are inhabited by concepts
which need to be explained as well
concepts like autoimmune disease and the
experimental idea that underlies the
question this book an idea called oral
tolerance so there are all these
disparate things to explain and to
connect in some way how do you deal with
this complexity that was the challenge
of this book and how do you provide the
reader with a guide rope one way a way
that's often used would be to introduce
myself into the book as a character and
this is done many times successfully a
book I love is a book called the spirit
catches you and you fall down by an
Fatima and in this wonderful book she is
a character in a player and interacts
with the various people who are in her
story but I decided not to do that I
played with it but ultimately decided
against it in other words I don't tie
the various stories together by saying
and then I went to New York and
interviewed the venture capitalists it
would have added yet another layer to
the story and it would have put up an
additional barrier between the reader
and the story which is the compelling
story of the quest the quest for the
cure so I've used instead a journalistic
convention of simply putting the reader
in the place though all of you as
sophisticated readers know that I'm
there all the time shaping the story
that convention of staying invisible in
the story was confining at times for
instance there was a moment when I
called one of the patients in a trial
and I had to tell her that the trial
hadn't succeeded and it was a very
dramatic moment she cried and I would
love to have been able to replicate to
just reproduce that exchange in the book
but since I wasn't a character in the
book I couldn't do that so I had to use
mizuno so and so was I don't know drying
her hair when she got the phone call
which told her that editor but the
convention has many advantages one as I
said is the immediacy that allows and
the other was that this story that I
tell in this book took place over 15
years and I was only there for the last
five but using this convention it's
possible to for all of us to pretend to
be in this kind of conspiracy together
that we're there through the whole 15
years and the one reason that I was able
to do this also to talk about the 15
years is that I had the good fortune of
having a main character a protagonist
will call him the principal scientist
who kept a journal and who was willing
to share it with me now this is a fairly
factual journal it's not particularly
introspective most of the time but it's
cumulative cumulatively over 15 years
it's a wonderful document you get a
sense of what's involved in this process
so but then so i didn't use I wasn't
going to use myself I decided but I
still had this question to answer how to
link the story so that the reader
doesn't get lost in the complexity and
is compelled forward I didn't want to
have any moments where the reader got
discouraged and put the book down saying
this is too complicated this is to TG
this too didactic and yet I had a lot of
information to convey
well one of the reasons one of the
things I did to solve this problem was
to keep the book short it's under 300
pages that was intentional and I'm
pleased about that I also decided not to
have and notes not to have bibliography
not even have an index someone a scholar
friend of mine said I never trust a book
that doesn't have an index in a
bibliography but this book wasn't
written for him and another solution was
to always clearly define for the reader
which room they were in in this
imaginary house and thus the chapter
titles of the book the first one is
called what is the first one called
forgotten already the clinic the disease
the lab director the researchers the big
idea the capitalists so that each each
of each chapter's is well defined so the
reader knows where he or she is and then
I kept as a touch tone and never strayed
too far from the quest the quest for a
cure for the disease many people in this
book were involved in some small part of
that quest for instance the I once went
to a conference that the CEO
participated in the Montgomery investors
was giving in New York and he gave a
presentation in which he never once
mentioned any of the diseases that he
was trying to find a cure for it was all
about other things was about it was
about the investment and business side
of it is nothing wrong with that it
wasn't crass it was just that was where
he was at but in order to keep the
reader engaged I wanted to stay with the
fact that this was about diseases that
affect and afflict human beings another
thing was to have the characters have
characters have real characters in the
book but not too many characters so the
reader could come to care about them and
to have this one main character my
protagonist Howard whiner whose story
dominates and whom the reader can care
about
and the book begins and ends with scenes
of howard whiner in the clinic with
patients now i'm going to read excerpts
you that take place in some of the
various rooms in that dollhouse I was
talking about what I hope to convey by
the end of the book is a sense of the
way in which many actors often at the
same time are participating in a vast
enterprise for very high stakes and i
hope you will get a sense of the very
human story and the tremendous heart
that goes into taking a promising idea
and turning it into a treatment for a
terrible diseases in this case the
target of the effort is autoimmune
disease in general and multiple
sclerosis and rheumatoid arthritis in
particular but my hope is that readers
will come away from the book with a
sense of how every promising idea for
treatment travels from laboratory bench
to bedside
chapter one the clinic most of
neurologists Howard whiners days are
spent in his laboratory or on the road
talking at conferences but on Tuesdays
he takes the white coat size 42 long
down from his office door pulls it on
over his blazer and walks from his lab
to the multiple sclerosis clinic at
Brigham and Women's a Harvard teaching
hospital in Boston on this particular
Tuesday it's windy and cold as he heads
across the mall of Harvard Medical
School his white coat slapping at a walk
that verges on the trot inside the
hospital he swings by the coffee shop
and picks up juice and a blueberry
muffin to be consumed between
consultations and hurries down the long
corridor everyone calls the pike on the
pike which connects the old and new
Brigham hospital buildings that have
accumulated over a century winer slows
momentarily to meet and greet other
white coats moving in the opposite
direction then he hurries across the
Grand hospital lobby and through the
neurology waiting area to the doctors
room where he scans the roster of
multiple sclerosis patients he will see
that morning as usual he recognizes most
of the names on the list many of them
are long-term patients and most of them
are not doing very well there are some
very sick people coming in today he says
softly Howard whiner is a fit six footer
with thick glasses that can make his
eyes look wild his hair used to be
abundant and curly but now that he's in
his 50s it slipped down and thinning on
top adding prominence to his nose he has
a gleaming smile that flash is often but
he is incapable of irony or sarcasm
because of his deep bass voice and his
earnestness one of his poker buddies
thinks he would have made a good rabbi
whiner however has chosen to devote
himself to another mission finding a
cure for Multiple Sclerosis even after
30 years of searching including many
setbacks and frustrations his zeal is
undiminished whiner has always been an
activist when it comes to treating
multiple sclerosis I think you've got to
be doing something he frequently
declares
to buttress his argument he sometimes
quotes a line from King Lear nothing
will come of nothing but the truth is
that much of the time multiple sclerosis
defeats his interventions that's why on
Tuesday evenings he so often writes in
his journal about how tough his day in
the clinic has been he doesn't like to
see people getting worse the first
patient on the roster this Tuesday
morning is new to him she is Harriet M a
43 year old from New Hampshire who is
experiencing numbness in one arm and has
come to get a second opinion Herod is a
small woman with curly bleached hair
that creates a halo around her face
she's wearing comfortable knit pants
which accommodate her slender waist and
full low hips and a short t top reveals
a little of her firm midriff her eyes
look puffy and tired but her skin is
smooth and youthful and her arms look
strong she lifts weights she tells
whiner takes care of herself winer
listens to Harriet's story a variation
on hundreds of others he has heard in
the MS clinic over the past 25 years 8
years ago she had a cold that resulted
in dizziness and numbness on one side of
her face her doctor referred her to an
ear specialist guessing that she
probably had an inner ear disturbance
related to the infection but for two
years after that whenever she looked at
her feet she got a strange sensation
strange sensation in her back when her
left arm began to get numb recently she
thought it might be because she had
carpal tunnel syndrome from her job that
was when her doctor mentioned ms as a
possibility the story has revealed a lot
to whiner probably the facial numbness
eight years ago was a first ms attack
most telling is the report that Harriet
has been feeling shocks down her spine
for the last two years when looking at
her feet this was probably the limit
sign caused by a lesion in the spinal
cord that increases pressure when the
neck is bent forward and down it is a
classic symptom of multiple sclerosis so
far though winer is going only on the
patient's history now he asked her to
sit on the end of the examining table so
they can run through the neurologic exam
Howard weinert likes to come prepared
his family teases him that he never
comes to home to Colorado without a set
of clothes for every kind of weather he
always carries an extra laser pointer
with him when he's giving a talk just in
case similarly whiner keeps his white
coat fully equipped for Clint clinic
days on one breast pocket is the white
plastic tag bearing the wavy crest of
the brigham next to the words Howard
whiner MD neurology and inside there's a
plastic I chart and a tuning fork for
testing sensations a black rubber reflex
hammer and stethoscope way down the
lower right pocket and as a prescription
pad lower left his car keys also
essential are dropped in at the last
minute now he taps Harriet's knee with
his reflex hammer he runs his car keys
along the arches of her feet noticing
that her right big toe turns up instead
of down as it would in a normal subject
he asks her to follow his finger with
him her eyes looking for dis conjugate I
movements which indicate that the
brainstem has been affected finally
whiner watches Harriet walk a slight bit
unevenly from one end of the court at
the brigham clinic to the other by the
time he's finished the neurologic exam
he strongly suspects that Harriet has an
MS Legion lesion affecting the left side
of her body but he won't say anything
until he's taken a look at the film she
brought along he carries the giant
manila envelope down to the doctors room
and throws the stiff films up two at a
time onto the view box very quickly he
finds the white spot a white spot on the
vertical ropes of brea that tells him
she has a lesion on the left side of her
spinal cord in the neck area and two
other lesions in the brain to whiner the
conclusion is now unavoidable this woman
has multiple sclerosis there are three
drugs on the market the target ms the
ABC avonex vadas Iran and Kopacz on the
ABC drugs as they are called in ms
circles have given you hope to patients
but they are not the cure the drugs can
reduce the MS attack rate by only about
thirty percent and they don't work in
all cases all three must be given by
injection on a frequent basis and there
are sometimes side effects in addition
to the ABC drugs chemotherapy agents are
gaining
acceptance for the treatment of certain
forms of rapidly advancing events but
these although sometimes dramatically
effective have worse side effects than
the ABC drugs about 15 years ago Howard
winer got an idea for an entirely new
and potentially revolutionary approach
to multiple sclerosis this approach if
successful could result in the safe oral
treatment not only for ms but also for
other diseases with similar autoimmune
characteristics from the moment he
discovered that the approach worked in
animals he believed its development was
going to be his crowning scientific
achievement the idea called oral
tolerance was ridiculed in the beginning
but it has since become the focus of
research in laboratories all over the
world so far no one has been able to
show conclusively that it works in
treating human disease sooner or later
whiner and says it has to work when that
happens I'll be a happy man for the New
Hampshire couple who have come to see
him on this Tuesday however such dreams
of future breakthroughs are no comfort
winer enters the room where harry and
her husband are waiting and hoist
himself onto a swivel stool with his
hands clasped around one knee he turns
to face the couple when you have only
one symptom he begins in his low pondras
voice then it's difficult to know if
it's ms but when a number of symptoms
point in the same direction as in this
case it becomes possible to make a
diagnosis then incongruously whiner
offers the New Hampshire couple a
big-city analogy when you see the Empire
State Building and central park and
madison square garden he tells them you
know you're in New York neither of them
is miles or even seems to hear what wine
has just said but then as he starts to
speak again the woman stops him wait a
minute she says in a trembling voice you
say you think I have MS it's not for
sure no whiner answers firmly it is ms i
have no doubt he continues ms is an
autoimmune disease of the nervous system
in which some of your cells attack your
own tissue you probably had a first
attack eight years ago and that's lucky
because there has been a long interval
between attacks but with MS it's
possible to know the future it's a
little like being in a boxing ring where
you keep getting hit by an invisible
opponent you may be in the ring with a
five-year-old who doesn't hit too hard
or you may be in there with a pro who
does none of this is registering with
the patient and only a little with her
husband do you understand why nor s well
right now I her voice trails off she's
staring at the floor about to cry
understanding will be a long and
complicated process solange which
introduces you to my protagonist and to
ms one of the autoimmune diseases that
this book is about now I want to
introduce you to the lab into the
characters one of the characters in the
lab a woman named Ruth Marrone Israeli
woman who I spent a good deal of time
with you will be able to tell even
though again I don't identify myself as
there that I was with her during these
events i'm reading about ruth is used to
tending the animal experiments she does
it on Saturdays and Sundays because it's
a long trip into the labs for her
technician but even when the mice are
producing great results she is still
troubled after all these years by the
animal work I find it stressful she says
I don't like treating living beings as
test tubes with a sad smile she tells of
her son's announcement that he was going
into computers instead of biology
because quote you've already killed
enough animals Ruth and others use the
word sacrifice to describe the killing
of animals in their work it is euphemism
that contains a justification the
animals are sacrificed for the good of
humankind what makes animal research
acceptable to Ruth and the others
involved in it are the results animal
research has produced cures for many
scourges including diphtheria
tuberculosis and polio almost everything
that is now known about autoimmune
disease has come from animal studies
there is a paradox however at the center
of animal research it is because the
body's the brains and sometimes even the
psyches of animal
are like ours that they make good models
for the study of human ailments and it
is because the animals are like us that
we have qualms about using them in this
way 50 yards or so on the other side of
longwood avenue Ruth enters into another
world the animal room in the warren
alpert building a cool grey granite
addition fused onto one wing of Harvard
Medical School security is tight here
but Ruth nods to the guard who knows her
well and swipes her plastic card to
unlock the door to the lab the protests
of animal rights activists have made
such precautions necessary also partly
because of the pressure from animal
rights groups the cages are large and
well maintained each of the thousands of
mice in this facility was purchased for
around fifteen dollars and is maintained
at about thirty three cents a day Ruth
describes the facility in fact as a
five-star hotel yet it is definitely a
rodent hotel from the moment Ruth passes
through the secured or the animal smell
is thick in the air in a dressing rooms
Ruth strips to her underwear and pulls
on blue surgical scrubs over her slim
figure slips to disposable booties over
his shoes and disposable cap over her
ponytail all of this is part of the
effort to keep pathogens away from the
animals in the control room the
attendant who monitors entries and exits
from behind glass tells Ruth that there
was a flood in one of her cages and the
animals died I don't think it was one of
the critical experiments she says but
we'll see using her card one more time
Ruth opens the door into a room of
stacked cages filled with hundreds of
mice there are many kinds of mice here
some black some white some with large
litters of tiny blind pups others was
older babies nursing at their mother's
tits each cage has a clean lining with
cedar chips and each has a card taped to
it that tells a story what breed the
mice are who the researcher is and
what's being done to them Ruth sets down
her supplies pulls on thin gloves
collects her thoughts and reaches for a
cage to begin her work swiftly she grabs
the pink tail of one of the little white
mice then with her other hand she takes
hold of it firmly by the
she wants to see if the mice in this
group are showing signs of eae which is
the mouse equivalent of ms the tail is a
good indicator of disease since
paralysis sets in there first some of
the mouse tails curl actively around
Ruth's finger indicating that they are
healthy but other tales are listless and
some of the mice are dragging whole rear
ends behind them using their front feet
Ruth observes and assesses each mouse
using scale in which 0 means no disease
in five means death she looks at their
fur which turns scruffy and loses its
lustrous white with disease and she
turns them over on their backs to see
how hard it is for the little creatures
to right themselves there are some would
become sicker and others who are getting
better in short the mice have ups and
downs similar to those experienced by
human patients with relapsing or
remitting multiple sclerosis before she
leaves Ruth sprays water on the food
pellets of the afflicted mice because
some of them have a hard time getting to
their water bottle in the animal room
Ruth works alone but back at the lab she
almost always has company usually the
two postdocs she is working closest with
at present Anthony slavin from Australia
and Gabriella Garcia who comes from
Brazil she tells them the good news that
the diabetic mice seem to be contracting
eae this is good news she tells them
about the flooding which fortunately
didn't reckon the experiments
conversation then turns as often happens
to mice in general Anthony's progress it
seems has been slowed by a major cell
death which has forced him to start over
breeding a new batch of mice and Ruth
remembers that when she was finishing
her PhD all the mice got some terrible
disease and had to be sacrificed she was
devastated but fortunately she had an
easygoing advisor who told her well this
way you finished your PhD sooner the
kind of genetically engineered mice
these researchers use are hard to
replace bread through sophisticated
processes on experimental mouse forms
they aren't always available in desired
numbers the Center for neurologic
diseases can rarely fill its standing
order yet without them the work can't go
for
word in the hierarchy of the lab the
mice may be at the bottom but like most
underlings they are what keeps the whole
operation going the mice Ruth Marrone
says laughing are more important than we
are well then we move on in my story to
discussion of the this big idea oral
tolerance which turned out to be a very
promising idea for treating autoimmune
disease the animal work showed that this
this approach might be a very promising
one to try and as soon as that happened
Howard whiner started thinking about the
next step and I'm going to jump way
forward to the time at which it really
seemed from limited human trials that
this was an idea that needed to be tried
out in major clinical trials and at that
stage in the process it becomes
necessary to find a lot of money na NIH
grants can support the early human
trials but when it comes to the large
clinical trials you need millions and
the way you get those means is to go to
venture capital and particularly since
1980 when it became possible for
institutions and hospitals in the public
sector to form partnerships with venture
capitalists this has been the way a lot
of research most research has come to
clinical trials so I'm going to move to
the chapter that's called the
capitalists and just describe the two
members of the CW group who did the
initial funding of this and who
organized the major fundraising that
went on when they did a roadshow and
raised 40 million dollars so these were
the first capitalists that got involved
one of one of them was a man named
Walter Channing who had connections to
to the Brigham and Women's Hospital
through his illustrious medical family
and who was a very adventurous investor
and the other was a man named Barry
Weinberg
and they the two of them formed the CW
group Walter Channing and Barry Weinberg
the C and W of the CW group have been
partners since nineteen sixty eight they
are an improbable duo Channing scion of
a distinguished Boston family grew up in
Dover genteel suburb of Boston attended
Milton Academy and Harvard followed by
harvard business school at the same time
Barry Weinberg was growing up in nearby
Roxbury a then Jewish neighborhood of
modest triple-deckers after Boston Latin
an exam school he graduated from MIT and
electrical engineering I had an uncle
who said electronics Weinberg explains
what did I know it turned out he hated
engineering so before long he decided to
go to business school choosing NYU over
Harvard because he got a scholarship
venture capitalists are gamblers who
count on a lot of failures and a few big
wins even though the industry has grown
enormously since Channing and Weinberg
began its assets are a fraction of those
available from commercial banks venture
capitalists however are willing to take
risks that banks won't and to work as
partners with entrepreneurs and getting
their ideas launched as venture
capitalists chatting and Weinberg turned
out to have complementary skills
Channing had good instincts about what
to invest in and was good at starting
from scratch and putting a deal together
raising money from people he knew and
who knew him Weinberg was good at
managing and believes that their hands
on approach during the startup phase of
new companies has been the secret of CW
success Weinberg is very methodical
according to Channing who is not
Weinberg's office just a few yards from
his partners could be in another
building from Channing's Channing's
unwalled space is bathed in sunlight and
his windows frame a charming rogue
brownstones along 61st Street Weinberg's
walled office is dark and overcrowded
there are files piled everywhere his
windows overlook the harsh black glass
and brass canopy of Trump Plaza home of
a large paint and wallpaper store on
Third Avenue like Channing he has his
own art on the wall
a strange dream like oil painting of a
man in an empty room a small trim man in
a well-made suit Barry Weinberg stands
with his back to the door staring out on
Third Avenue and talking on the phone
with someone who wants him to invest in
a start-up company do you have Dava
Barry at is asking the petitioner as he
listens to the long answer he turns and
riffles the pages of the proposal under
discussion which is sitting on his desk
clearly he is not impressed we've been
in the venture capital business for 30
years Weinberg tells the collar and we
invest in the health field only so we
have a lot of experience how is this
different than better than previous
technology another long answer your
capitalization strategy i think is a
little naive says Weinberg then adds
without much conviction I don't mean to
be demeaning Weinberg tells the caller
to send more data and agrees reluctantly
to a lunch date in New York we see about
1500 investment opportunities a year
Weinberg says we typically make four or
five investments when companies have
failed according to Weinberg has often
been because of the inflexibility of the
leading scientists or executive we have
become very very sensitive to the nature
of the person we back he says we've seen
many projects over the years in which we
were fascinated by the technology and
the ideas but did not feel the scientist
was suitable for us the course of drug
development is never predictable
Weinberg explains unforeseen and
untoward things happen along the way and
you've got to deal with them and that
means not being stiff necked not only
knowing your stuff but being able to sit
down and talk with people and listen
Howard winer impressed Weinberg is the
kind of person the CW group could work
with an honest person a good scientist
he didn't have a lot of respect for the
commercial world but he observed and was
willing to adjust and so began the
partnership of the CW group and Howard
winer out of that partnership of CEO was
hired for the company and it was a
little like the farmer in the Dell you
know the CEO takes the vice president
and he takes another vice president and
before you know it you've got six or
seven employees and
Howard wine of the principal scientist
and the CEO went out on what's called
the roadshow two places all over the
world whether were investors willing to
listen to their story and sat in private
rooms over very fancy meals and
explained there they're promising idea
for treating oral for treating
autoimmune disease Society of oral
tolerance and they raised on that first
go around that first Roadshow 39 million
dollars and then they had initial public
offering stock went up and down as they
do with these unknown ideas went as high
as 15 I think at one point maybe even
higher but the truth was as everybody
knew nothing would really be known until
there were clinical trials and until
their worries results from clinical
trials and here's where my story really
broadens and widens out to include many
many people this trial the first trial
they had in multiple sclerosis was a
trial that involved 500 patients and in
sites I think there were 14 or 15 trial
sites all over the United States and
Canada and each of these sites there was
a doctor a principal investigator who
was recruiting patients to the trial
until they had these 500 patients then
they had a two-year trial just give you
a sense of what a long process this is
so then there's a two-year trial at the
end of which there will be results I'm
not going to give away the end of the
story but I'm going to read you one last
excerpt about a patient in the trial
actually the very last patient to enroll
in this in the miler all trial and so
here that is
entirely by chance the last patient to
enroll in the mile or all trial and the
last patient to finish was a 29 year old
graduate student named Nicholas H who
lived in Montreal so the last of several
thousand of the MRI films that were
taken in the mile all study didn't have
to be packed up and sent by air instead
it was hand carried down the hall should
explain that the the MRI films were all
analyzed at the in Montreal so this last
patient happened to be in Montreal
Nicholas H grew up in Greece and arrived
in the northerly climate of Montreal at
the age of 17 he sometimes wondered if
he might have avoided ms altogether if
he hadn't left home a marathoner who had
his first attack after a long run he
wondered too if the running might not
precipitate attacks or if the infectious
mononucleosis he contracted shortly
after arriving in Canada might have
something to do with it most of all he
wondered about his future Nicholas was a
tall young man with a handsome aqualine
profile a radiant smile and large brown
eyes with long lashes that had a
slightly stunned look in them even
though he came from the Mediterranean he
welcomed the cold of Montreal winter and
was well prepared for it moving quickly
along isolated sidewalks in his hooded
jacket this is my ideal time he
explained all my attacks have been in
the summer the summer after he entered
the miler all study Nicholas didn't have
an attack that made him hopeful and he
took up running again but then he had
two attacks and fairly quick succession
and that caused that cause numbness in
his legs after that he hoped he was on
the placebo the sugar pill not the real
drug like everyone else in the trial he
wanted to believe that my Laurel could
change his life Nicholas's graduate work
was an experimental psychology so he
studied the brain and was able to follow
developments and MS research but that
didn't make it any easier to know the
future and what it would bring because
of his ms he felt more pressure to
finish his PhD and get established
somewhere he wanted to remain in
academia because it was what he loved
and because he believed the academic
community would be tolerant of someone
the disability yet he sometimes thought
it would be wiser to get a job in the
pharmaceutical industry because that way
he could make more money quickly and
save up and Casey became disabled I
mainly get sent for sensory symptoms
Nicholas explained but what if the next
symptom was a motor symptom and I
couldn't work very well you always think
about that on Tuesday March 18th 1997 at
little before two in the afternoon
Nicholas H walked up the hill to the mni
the Montreal Neurological Institute the
limestone fortress penfield built and
headed for the MRI unit there he climbed
up onto a narrow concave table and lay
perfectly still as a technician slit a
white plastic basket resembling a
birdcage over his head then the table
slid slowly into a tunnel so narrow that
he could feel the sides of it along his
arms and hips there was a microphone
inside the space so patients who became
claustrophobic could ask for help but
Nicholas the calm scientist managed his
session in the dimly lit lit MRI tunnel
without too much difficulty he lay
immobilized in the tubular prison
waiting for the noises of the MRI
created by the magnets pull on the
machines metal parts to begin first came
a talk talk the sound of a ball-peen
hammer tapping somewhere near his head
men allowed her steadier sound like a
pneumatic drill doing double time been
silenced the ball-peen hammer again and
other sounds this time more like the
alarms that plastic security tag set off
at the door of a department store then
doubling of that sounds hell it began to
resemble a philip glass piece after 45
minutes the set of films of Nicholas
brain was complete and the my Laran
trial was officially over at long last
the researchers conducting the trial
could take off their blinders and all
those who had placed their hopes in my
Laurel could find out if it worked I'm
going to end there
thank you we have time can we go right
right away
Oh
ah the question while Howard whiner
likes to say when confronted with the
difficulty of finding a cure that the
low hanging fruit has been picked very
complicated challenges and I don't think
anyone can answer your question really
how far the cure is away I'll leave it
there I have to also remind you that i'm
a journalist so certain I I was on a
radio program when people were calling
me up and asking me advice about what
drugs they should be taking I had to
make a disavowal yes patent and event
the story represents an interesting
issue between the the scientists is a
pure research scientist and entering the
business world and the the realm of the
business world in the science world you
know the University and the business for
profit not for for public you etc how do
you explore that and what have you
learned about that that issue I think in
many ways the book is about how money
affects science and Howard minor is
someone like all research scientists who
has had to struggle to get grants
throughout his career and this has you
and I'm sure others here no it's a very
time-consuming and discouraging an
aggravating process and then you have so
you had there's that kind of money
there's one there's one point in this
story where Howard wider has been turned
down for a grant and is feeling
aggravated about it and at the same time
is talking with these venture
capitalists the grant was I think maybe
four thirty thousand dollars can't
remember the venture capitalists are
talking in the millions they only talk
in millions so they're talking three
four million just start up to do a fuel
experiments so you know this is very
seductive also the money is necessary
these large clinical trials couldn't be
done without it at the same time when
you have venture capital involved in
science the clock is ticking I'm these
are people who want a return on their
and no matter how much they claim
they're willing to wait there's pressure
to move quickly my feeling of after
writing the story is it probably the
pressure of the clock ticking cause some
decisions to be made that shouldn't have
been made I think they probably moved
too quickly i think everyone to agree at
this point in retrospect that they move
too quickly into phase 3 trials this
remains a very promising idea and then
there's two ongoing trials now using
this and it may be that the that in fact
it will turn out to be a successful
treatment for ms but i do think that the
effect of the venture capital was to
move things quickly into phase 3 trials
also my explore the whole area of the
interface between the company autoimmune
inc the small biotech company and the
physicians who are on the front line
with patients and the way there's a
certain there is a kind of pressure for
physicians first of all to recruit
patients they get paid by the patient
I've never was able to find out if I got
inside a lot but I never did actually
get a hard figure on how much autoimmune
was paying per patient in this trial
partly because they pay different
amounts to different places depending on
whether it's a prestigious research
institute or whether it's a physician in
private practice of so there's money
involved in recruiting patients there's
money involved in keeping the patients
in the trial there may be times when
their rescue medications might be
appropriate but the doctor might not
want to use them because it would mean
that the person would have to be taken
out of the trial patients should know by
the way that they always have the option
of coming out of a trial but that
creates certain kinds of precious
intentions there's also the interesting
tension between the company who want to
keep the trial clean and don't want the
doctors using all kinds of extra
medications to help their patients and
the pen and the doctors who by and large
think in terms of helping individual
patients so the vice president of
autoimmune said one of them said to me
at one point you can't think about
individual patients when you
in this business you think about the
greater good in the long run for the
large number of people but doctors think
about should think about as you know
individual patients so that's attention
there there a lot of tensions in these
interfaces there's another tension about
information and whether it should be
revealed or not the tradition in
academia is that you that you tell all
and in fact your whole reputation rests
on having other people replicate your
research so you need to publish your
work and to have it tested by other
researchers and that's the way you
that's the way that world works and the
and the coin of the realm in research is
really reputation the coin of the realm
and business is money and that means
patents and patent lawyers want to
protect information so there have been
numerous instances in which researchers
have been put under pressure not to
reveal the results of their work because
it would be bad for the company and
sometimes they've had and they have
entered into agreements which actually
silence them and this is this is a bad
thing no doubt I must say I I was
appalled that a Wall Street Journal
review of my book used it as an argument
for for no limitations on drug prices
and for just total justification of Big
Pharma's large prices etc and I don't
think my book is an advocate of that but
what my book what I did in my book I
didn't look for the the bad guys if I
wanted to do an investigative book about
people who were abusing the system and
who were being swayed or influenced in
very serious ways by money I wouldn't
have chosen Howard wine I wouldn't have
chosen these people these were dedicated
people and there may have been some what
they call dry lab and you know that
which is sort of inventing patients a
result I mean that might even have
happened with these trials it does
happen with others so that's a key
question it's it money runs through the
book
it's all over the place
my wife and I thoroughly enjoyed the
book thank you just a fantastic job of
capturing oral tolerance and dr. Wyner
and I have one request in one hope the
request is that you continue to follow
dr. Wyner and progress of oral tolerance
my one hope is that you go back into the
journal and you learn more about his
poker plane so that the future I can
beat him ah there's one of his poker
buddies not the one who said he should
be a rabbi though I'd like to
acknowledge that dr. Howard whiner is
here tonight and I'm very pleased that
he is Howard could he's standing over
there I'm not sure that's gonna be on
television or not okay but the next to
last the next to last chapter of my book
is called the end and the last chapter
is called the beginning and that is
because even though there were some
disappointing results in this particular
trial there are very many other
promising developments since then and
I'm hoping in the paperback edition of
the book that I'm going to be able to
have an addendum that says we got oral
tolerance to work in human disease I
think there's no doubt it's going to
happen and there are trials ongoing teva
and Israeli based companies now doing a
very large trial in multiple sclerosis
there's some very promising findings
also in Alzheimer's disease and there
are some positive findings and diabetes
now so all told there is a reason to
keep keep watching stay tuned
I'm curious as to how you latched on to
this particular idea where it came from
was your original intent to sort of
profile human trials or was it did it
really initiate as more of a biography I
I guess the person came first and then
the idea of the book came after i had a
known Howard whiner sort of lose a
friend of her friend and I heard him
talking one night but he was just in the
process when I happened to have dinner
at someone's house and he was talking
about how he was raising millions of
dollars for this very very promising
idea and it's it was actually my husband
and said that's your next book I didn't
think so but you know what winds up
being right and what made it very
appealing was that Howard was willing to
become very open with me once he decided
to do it it took him a long time to
decide to do it but once he decided to
do it we really had a good agreement a
signed agreement that i could write
whatever I wanted to write you have this
I think is a very admirable scientific
attitude which is the facts are there
and you can do with them what you will
he the only proviso was a he could
correct facts that were wrong so I had
freedom in that way and i also had
access to these journals and that was
quite remarkable to have that access and
then also because he was had agreed to
cooperate he opened doors for me at the
company so for instance on the morning
when they got an announcement of
negative results I was supposed to be
there that morning at nine and one of
the vice president's said to Howard
maybe we should tell her not to come and
he said nope she should come so i was
there i was there when they announced
these results was there when they told
the employees that they were going to be
layoffs i was i was there for all that
painful stuff and that i think is what
makes the book powerful i hope
it's
thank you pick up a copy of Susan's book
get it signed thank you everyone for
coming thank you
hey